pour la deuxième fois des sources
diplomatiques françaises font fuiter
dans la presse le contenu de
conversations entre emmanuel macron et
vladimir poutine
sans oublier d'arranger à leur façon le
sens de ces échanges
moscou est plus que déçu certains
cercles essaye de former une atmosphère
toxique au tour de la russie
il est impossible de croire que nos
homologues français ont transmis aux
médias à l'enregistrement de la
conversation entre vladimir poutine et
emmanuel macron il ne pouvait tout
simplement pas faire cela par conséquent
nous avons été très perplexe d'apprendre
un deuxième cas de publication dans la
presse d'un fragment prétendument
authentique d'une autre conversation
l'affirmation de l'auteur citant une
source diplomatique anonyme pour appuyer
l'authenticité des documents est
particulièrement préoccupante
en fait les médias ont de nouveau
divulguer le contenu délibérément
déformé des conversations entre des
chefs d'état la source diplomatique
citée par le magazine challenges raconte
ainsi que vladimir poutine aurait
demandé l'aide des manuels macron afin
de produire le très controversé l'accent
russe qui ce site pourtant l'intérêt de
50 pays alors qu'au contraire le
président français s'efforcerait depuis
des semaines d'éviter que des
scientifiques français collabore avec
leurs homologues russes sauf que le
journaliste de challenges semble bien
mal informé ou oublier le mentionner
puisque trois semaines après la
publication de l'article
une délégation française menée par la
directrice de l'inserm l'institut
national de santé de la recherche
médicale est arrivé à moscou pour
obtenir des informations sur les vaccins
russe la source diplomatique française
mentionné par challenges avance
également ceux ci
depuis plusieurs semaines les russes
nous demandent si nous voulons
travailler avec eux précise un diplomate
français
en réalité cela traduit leur principale
faiblesse
ils n'ont pas de capacités de production
malgré leurs faiblesses les russes ont
tout de même décroché un accord avec
l'une des plus grandes sociétés
pharmaceutiques indiennes hétéro
biopharma pour produire plus de 100
millions de doses annuelles du vaccin
spoutnik v et ce n'est qu'un début
des accords de production conjointe du
vaccin avec le brésil la corée du sud ou
encore la chine sont déjà dans les
tuyaux
le remède russe sera donc produit avec
la france ou sans